un día quiero hacerles una invitación
quiero invitar a todas las mujeres que
están acá
aquí nunca
cuando entré a la universidad empecé a
estudiar y me empecé a meter en este
mundo y después entré a trabajar me
interesan
identificar los rankings de las mujeres
líderes en el mundo instituciones muy
importantes hacia en estos rankings
y tenía en mi cabeza muchas preguntas
que quería buscar alguna respuesta
quería ver cómo estas mujeres habían
logrado llegar a donde habían llegado
cómo estaban ahí cómo habían enfrentado
sus desafíos cómo habían solucionado sus
problemas y yo quería ser una de esas
mujeres empecé a investigar del tema
empecé a buscar literatura me encontré
con una gran cantidad de libros paper
documentos artículos que traían
información muy enriquecedora muy
interesante muchos ejemplos muchas
buenas prácticas mucha teoría respecto a
cómo las mujeres pueden transformarse en
líderes
pero si hay tanta literatura si hay si
somos tantas las que tratamos de
empoderarnos porque los rankings siguen
siendo tan escasos para las mujeres
porque tan pocas mujeres que logran
llegar a puestos gerenciales a puestos
directivos a tener cargos importantes en
ong que nos pasa
hay literatura hay rankings hay charlas
pero de alguna forma no somos capaces de
aumentar esas cifras
empecé a buscar respuestas
y trate de buscar en distintos ejemplos
en mí en mi vida profesional
y me encontré con una fundación
una fundación cuyo propósito es valorar
cuidar y que todos acción acceder a una
sonrisa de calidad
esta fundación se encarga de educar a la
sociedad respecto a la preocupación por
la higiene bucal
esta fundación también se encarga de
entregarles tratamientos dentales a
personas que económicamente no tienen
cómo acceder a ellos
gracias a esta linda fundación empecé a
encontrar mi respuesta y conocí a muchas
mujeres muchas mujeres que tuvieron
acceso a un tratamiento a su tratamiento
dental a la reconstitución de sus
dientes sobre todo los los dientes de
adelante que nos permiten sonreír
y me encontré con ejemplo muy lindo
cuando estas mujeres terminadas su
tratamiento y empezamos a conversar con
ellas te das cuenta que formaron familia
encontraron pareja tuvieron hijos son
presidentes de la junta de vecinos
armaron sus propios locales sus
almacenes hoy día son mujeres
empoderadas
lograron aumentar sus rentas y lograron
desarrollarse estas mujeres con quiero
sus sueños enfrentaron un desafío cuando
todo era difícil de enfrentar ellas se
atrevieron ella y un montón más que
están detrás
y esas limitaciones quiero hacer hoy día
les quiero contar el caso de la maria
damaris es una chica en la cuarta de
cinco hermanos
vive en una población muy vulnerable de
mucha pobreza y de mucha drogadicción
el 2012 ella decidió y luchó por entrar
a estudiar a la universidad
fue difícil yo creo que la ve cara y
entró a estudiar ese mismo año
a su papá le diagnosticaron cáncer
y su mamá entra en un proceso de
depresión profundo
los siguientes dos años va a amar y tuvo
que luchar por trabajar para llevar
plata para su casa
tratar de estudiar para sacar su carrera
de pedagogía
y cuidar a su papá que cada día se
deteriora más su salud y necesitaba cada
vez más apoyo
ante esta situación cualquiera de
nosotras baja los brazos
el 2014 el papá de la marina muere
y su mamá hasta el día de hoy no ha
logrado recuperarse de la depresión
pero de amar y decidió cambiar su vida
decidió esforzarse el doble o el triple
sacar su carrera seguir trabajando
y cuidar a su hermano y su familia
hoy día dameri después de terminar a
estudiar está haciendo un diplomado fue
becada
y un día trabaja en una ong
ella está a cargo de 30 jóvenes
que están estudiando en la universidad
son primera generación al igual que ella
y la misión que ella tiene
es que estos 30 jóvenes no deserten la
universidad en las mismas condiciones
que damaris estuvo desde el 2012 hasta
que terminó su carrera
la historia de damaris y la historia de
muchas mujeres que he conocido gracias a
esta fundación ha cambiado mi
pensamiento respecto al liderazgo
femenino
las mujeres líderes no son sólo aquellas
que salen en los rankings te les mostré
no son sólo aquellas que logran cargos
importantes gerenciales que son
directoras de empresa o que tienen un
importante rol en una ong
las mujeres líderes somos todas nosotras
todas nosotras que nos atrevemos a tomar
el desafío que ante cualquier problema
logramos que enfrentarlo hacernos cargo
y salir adelante
y ese es el concepto que quiero que me
ayuden a incorporar
el liderazgo
es la capacidad que tenemos de enfrentar
los desafíos y cumplir nuestros sueños
y eso explica para cualquier etapa de
nuestras vidas y para cualquier ámbito
en cualquier situación nosotros tenemos
que ser capaces de enfrentar nuestros
desafíos y de cumplir nuestros sueños
es por eso que le quiero hacer una
invitación
piensen en una cosa en un gran sueño que
tengan da lo mismo en qué contexto
familiar personal de relaciones laboral
el que ustedes quieran el que sea
importante para ustedes no para el resto
podría la noche cuando se vayan a costar
piensen en este sueño
y busquen como cumplirlo enfrenten los
desafíos se van a encontrar con
problemas algunos vamos a fracasar
tratando de cumplir nuestros sueños
pero no bajen los brazos estoy segura
que eso fracaso esos problemas o esos
conflictos que podamos tener para
cumplir nuestros sueños nos van a hacer
más robustas vamos a tener más fuerza
para enfrentar el siguiente desafío y el
siguiente sueño
espero
y les pido
que cumplan sus sueños y que nunca pero
nunca dejen de brillar gracia
[Aplausos]